the sound of stun grenades reverberate
around Tahrir Square in Baghdad on
Friday dozens of protesters were
overcome by clouds of tear gas they
chanted free Baghdad corrupt officials
out from Iraq's capital to the southern
city of Karbala Iraqis demanded the
resignation of prime minister Adel Abdel
Mahadi and his government they are not
men of state that's all they cannot do
anything they cannot manage very little
school not this big country with the
nationwide protests were on the first
anniversary of Mahadi taking office
there also a continuation of protests
which began at the beginning of the
month that have killed 149 civilians and
8 members of the security forces the
government acknowledges excessive force
was used they call it a democracy but
the hands they used to wield this
democracy are dictators when they kill
their people with snipers it's not
democracy in addition to promising to
punish those responsible for killing
protesters Mahadi announced that he and
other government leaders will cut their
salaries by half and divert the money to
a fund to help the poor
he's also vowing to reshuffle the
government next week
prioritizing qualifications before party
or sect the years we heard about reforms
it's just a sleeping pill to calm the
people all of us are rejecting this
corrupt government protesters are
primarily young men desperate for jobs
they can't find in a country where the
gap between rich and poor only seems to
grow I'm jobless I have 24 cents that's
all the television stations see me this
is all I have
protesters say they want to live in an
independent Iraq not one that's a puppet
of the United States and Iran the office
of an Iranian backed armed group was
torched in the southern city of Samoa
the Prime Minister says if the
government resigns now chaos will follow
protesters remain unmoved
they say the solution is for a new
government to take over
Natacha guy named al jazeera Baghdad